[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
leckere selbst gemachte berliner bzw
kreppel je nachdem wie man sie bei euch
nennt ich zeige euch auch ein paar
wichtige tipps und tricks damit euch das
ganze auch wunderbar gelingt und die am
ende richtig schöne berliner habt
[Musik]
neben der klassischen variante zeige ich
euch auch eine mit nutella und zimt
zucker
jetzt kommen wir aber zuallererst zu den
zutaten für den teig für 14 große
berliner benötigen wir mehr frische hefe
etwas lauwarme milch zerlassene butter
zucker salz ein ganzes und 3 eigelb die
genauen mengenangaben schreibe ich euch
wie immer unten in die infobox in meine
rührschüssel gebe ich zu allererst das
mehl und bildet dann eine kleine mulde
in der mitte dort gebe ich dann die
lauwarme milch hinein und zerbrösele
dann die frische hefe damit hinein
[Musik]
hinzu kommt dann noch etwas von unserem
zucker das ist der nährstoff für unsere
hilfe und dann verrühren wir das ganze
in der mulde ganz leicht mit dem löffel
gerade so dass sich alles verbindet
anschließend wird das abgedeckt und zehn
minuten lang ruhen gelassen
es ist wichtig dass eure milch nicht zu
kalt und nicht zu warm ist wenn sie
unter 32 grad ist dann kann die hefe
sich leider nicht aktivieren und wenn
sie über 38 grad ist im zerstört ihr
dadurch die hefe und auch dann wird sie
nicht aktiviert nach zehn minuten ist
das ganze ein wenig schwammig und hat
sich ausgedehnt und dann gehen wir die
restlichen zutaten mit hinzu
[Musik]
das sind zucker zerlassene butter auch
die solltet ihr schon abgekühlt haben
also sollte nicht zu heiß sein dann
kommt noch die prise seiten zu das hebt
den süßen geschmack
außerdem die eigelbe und das volk
[Musik]
ich gebe das ganze in einer
küchenmaschine und knete das etwa fünf
minuten mit meinem knethaken auch hier
gilt wie immer ihr könnt das ganze auch
mit euren händen verkneten und dadurch
wieder teig auch nicht schlechter
denn ihr wisst ja küchenmaschine ist
kein muss es geht immer auch alles mit
den händen
[Musik]
nach etwa fünf minuten auf der mittleren
stufe ist der teig schon mal zusammen
geknetet und er ist sehr klebrig das ist
auch ganz normal und das ist vollkommen
richtig so
und dann gebe ich ihnen nur noch auf
meine arbeitsfläche die ich vorher mit
mehl ein wenig aus gedeckt habe und
kredite den dann zu einer kugel
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann eine schöne kugel
erhalten habt gebt ihr den teig zurück
in eure schüssel hier gebe ich auf den
schüssel boden noch mal ein wenig mehl
und auch über den teig damit er nichts
an klebt und bedenke dass wieder mit
einem tuch
[Musik]
nach etwa einer stunde an einem schönen
kuschelig warmen ort so hatte hefeteig
nämlich am liebsten geben wir den
aufgegangenen hefeteig auf unsere
arbeitsfläche am besten bemühte ihn
vorher wieder so klebt euch nicht an und
dann rollen wir ihn aus hier dürft ihr
den teig auch nicht nochmal kneten
ich drücke ihnen einfach flach und wenn
ihr vorher eine richtig schöne grunde
kugel gemacht habe dann ist er auch
wirklich sehr schön glatt und ihr könnt
ihn einfach ausrollen und ausstechen
den teig habe ich etwa 1 cm dick
ausgerollt ich würde auch nicht mehr als
eineinhalb zentimeter nehmen weil die
berliner dann schon sehr dick werden
hier habe ich einfach den deckel von
einer vorratsdosen genommen und er hat
einen durchmesser von neuneinhalb cm
[Musik]
sobald die kreise dann ausgestochen
wurden wird der teig noch mal zu einer
kugel geformt und geknetet und
anschließend erneut ausgerollt
[Musik]
eine schöne runde teig kugel erhaltet
ihr indem ihr den teig von außen nach
innen schiebt und dann immer so ein
drückt in der mitte sowie hier auch im
video gezeigt und dann mit den
handinnenflächen einfach schön kneten
und wenn ihr mögt dann auch auf der
arbeitsfläche noch mal so wie hier
gezeigt und denkt dran
je glatter und runder euro kugel ist es
so schöner werden die berliner dann
später beim auspacken
[Musik]
nachdem dann auch hier alle kreise
ausgestochen wurden geben wir darüber
ein tuch jetzt müssen die teig rohlinge
nochmals 30 minuten gehen
hier ist wirklich geduld gefragt denn
wenn ihr das nicht gehen lassen dann
werden eure berliner nicht so wie sie
sein sollen sondern einfach nur flach
für das frittieren habe ich einen ganz
tollen tipp für euch wir erhitzen das öl
so lange bis sich an einem holzstab zum
beispiel von einem kochlöffel blasen
bilden dann wird die hitze allerdings
bis zur hälfte runtergeschaltet das
heißt wenn ihr die stufe 8 habt macht es
runter auf die stufe 4
und dann wartet ihr fünf minuten und
anschließend bilden sich nur noch ganz
kleine blasen dann ist das öl genau
richtig ihr braucht auch kein
thermometer für diesen schritt und hier
gebe ich auch immer erst ein berliner
ins öl gebe da den deckel drüber und
dann werde ich das ganze nach exakt zwei
minuten und dann habt ihr so einen
schönen berliner
bei der nächsten kurve gebe ich dann
gerne mehrere berliner in den topf gibt
am besten so viel wie reinpassen
allerdings solltet ihr immer ein wenig
platz zum wenden lassen
für das frittieren ist der deckel des
topfes auch sehr entscheidend den dürft
ihr auf keinen fall weg lassen also
macht er definitiv direkt den deckel
drauf und wendet das ganze nach
spätestens zwei minuten
[Musik]
und weil so viele am fred ihr vorgang
scheitern beziehungsweise verzweifeln
und ich eben so erkläre ich euch nochmal
meine vorgehensweise ich erhitze das öl
in einem topf nicht auf der höchsten
stufe
zum beispiel habe ich die stufen neun
auf meinem herz und nehme da die stufe 8
dann erhebt sich das ganze bis ich an
meinem holzstab blasen bilden
danach nehme ich die hälfte von der
stufe die ich eingestellt habe das ist
bei mir die stufe 4 gewesen und lasse
das ganze fünf minuten stehen nach fünf
minuten gebe ich zur probe wieder mein
holzstab hinein und dann bilden sich nur
noch langsam und kleine blasen dann ist
das frittierfett perfekt und die
berliner können frittiert werden
ihr solltet auch auf jeden fall die zeit
stoppt nimmt dafür zb euer handy das hat
der jeder immer zur hand und dann müsst
ihr auf jeden fall schauen über zwei
minuten würde ich die berliner nicht
frittieren werden sie ziemlich dunkel
die letzten berliner haben zum beispiel
auch nur eine minute 45 gedauert denn
das fett verhält sich ja auch immer
anders also stoppt auf jeden fall die
zeit und behaltet sie im auge
[Musik]
die fertigen berliner können dann auf
einem küchentuch abtropfen und auskühlen
[Musik]
nachdem alle schwierigen hürden
gemeistert sind können wir die berliner
endlich erfüllen
und ich nehme hier ein teil und befülle
ihnen mit waldfrucht marmelade hier
könnt ihr natürlich die marmelade nehmen
die ihr am liebsten mit und den anderen
teil befülle ich mit nutella
[Musik]
an den seiten befehligt haben das ganze
ohne spritze die marmelade so lange raus
bis der berliner voll ist wenn ihr das
den händen haltet dann merkt er dass
auch wieder sich langsam füllt und etwas
schwerer wird und welche teile ihr hier
benutzt ist eigentlich vollkommen egal
wichtig ist und dass es irgendeine thüle
ist denn die braucht ihr damit ihr euch
durch den teig bauen könnt
[Musik]
das gleiche machen wir dann mit nutella
hier nehme ich dann auch wieder meine
spritztour nicht durch den teig am
besten von der seite und befülle das
ganze
[Musik]
meine nutella berliner wälze ich
anschließend noch in zimt zucker das
habe ich hier schon vorbereitet und
früher das kurz und dann zeige ich euch
noch eine andere variante wie berliner
mit nutella füllen könnt hierfür wird
der berliner im zimt zucker gewälzt und
anschließend aufgeschnitten
[Musik]
anschließend geben wir da rein nutella
und verschließen den deckel wieder
[Musik]
die variante finde ich persönlich auch
sehr schön anzusehen und wenn ich das so
sehe könnte ich da auch direkt
reinbeißen aber entscheidet ihr einfach
was euch am liebsten gefällt die
restlichen note aller berliner werden
jetzt selbstverständlich auch noch im
zimt zucker gewälzt
[Musik]
auf die klassischen berliner siebe ich
noch etwas puderzucker
hier müsst ihr nur beachten dass die
berliner komplett ausgekühlt sind
[Musik]
und das sind unsere fertigen berliner
falls ihnen jetzt auch nach machen
möchte dann schaut man in die infobox
dort stehen wir immer alle informationen
zu den mengenangaben und auch tipps und
tricks und falls ihr die berliner
fleißig nach macht dann schickt mir noch
gerne fotos über instagram oder postet
sie mit dem hashtag ekis kitchen falls
ihr kein video mehr verpassen möchte
dann abonniert den kanal kostenlos und
ich freue mich aufs nächste mal tschüss